The qualities that
investors are looking for
in a company I think can boil
down to three questions.
The first is, is the market big enough?
Is there enough opportunity out there
for a company to go out and succeed?
The second question is,
is the problem that you're trying to
solve something that's important?
Is it something that a lot of
people believe is an actual problem
that needs to be solved?
And the third thing is,
is your company best positioned to solve
that problem better than anybody else?
And you have to ask yourself
those three questions.
There's one other thing
you have to look at.
And that is that for early stage
investors, they're looking for
a 20 to 100 return on their money.
And when you think about your problem
and you think about taking money and
what you will ultimately be
able to return, you have to ask
yourself the question, can you return
that much money to the investor?
And if you can't,
then you probably need to go back and
re-evaluate the problem that
you're trying to solve.